[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the top five
most inspirational things albus
dumbledore ever said
to harry potter born in 1881 dumbledore
was well over a hundred actually 111 to
be exact when he first encounters harry
as a young boy
so it goes without saying that albus
dumbledore was likely a source of
inspiration
for many other witches and wizards in
the magical world who knew him before
harry potter
just take his obituary for example where
fellow wizard
ministry of magic jurist member of the
order of the phoenix
and close friend of dumbledore's since
childhood elvis
doge describes him as the most inspiring
and the best loved of all hogwarts
headmasters
all this to say dumbledore was obviously
an inspirational wizard to many
in fact throughout the canon harry often
overhears dumbledore saying
inspirational things to several other
characters but in this video
we're going to focus on the most
inspiring things dumbledore ever said
to harry potter himself let's take a
look
we're going to make our way through
these quotes in order of appearance
which brings us to quote number one in
which dumbledore shares an inspiring
piece of advice with harry
in the very first book harry potter and
the philosopher's stone
where he says it does not do to dwell on
dreams
and forget to live in this quote harry
has just made his way to secretly visit
the mirror of erised
a magical mirror that shows the viewer
their deepest desires
what he doesn't realize is that he's not
alone dumbledore is there as well
but before harry realizes that
dumbledore is in the room with him
he longingly stares into the mirror of
erised which by the way
reads as desire when spelled backwards
in fact there's also an inscription
above the mirror
that spells i should not your face but
your heart's desire
when read backwards harry in front of
the mirror of erised
sees himself surrounded by his dead
parents lily and james potter
as well of the rest of the potter family
whom he's never met
this brings dumbledore's advice into
better perspective for he sees how much
harry would love to stand in front of
the mirror
all day and dream of what it would be
like if his family was still alive
but if he were to do so he would waste
away his life dreaming of what could
never be
and if harry were to spend his life
dreaming of the things he cannot have
and that are simply not possible we
would never see him go on
to do all the incredible things he
accomplishes as a young wizard
next up we have an inspiring quote from
harry potter in the chamber of secrets
in this book dumbledore shares with
harry it is our choices harry that show
what we truly are
far more than our abilities this
exchange takes place
after harry comes out of the chamber of
secrets confessing to dumbledore that he
believes the only reason
the sorting hat placed him in gryffindor
during the sorting ceremony
and not slytherin like the hat was
considering was because he asked it to
dumbledore's reaction catches harry and
possibly the reader off guard
he doesn't seem to be surprised
unleashed in fact he seems to have known
that this was something harry asked if
the sorting hat all along he responds by
saying to harry
exactly which makes you very different
from tom riddle
tom riddle of course being voldemort's
name as a boy
with this speech he is showing harry how
he's in control of his own destiny
and not the other way around this
inspirational piece of advice is pivotal
in helping steer harry
towards a path of morally good choices
in which he feels in control of
rather than faltering to a perceived
destiny that may have prevented him
from ultimately defeating voldemort our
third quote is along the same theme as
the previous one
dumbledore once again hands home the
idea of individuals
being in control of their own destiny in
harry potter and the goblet of fire
when he says it matters not to what
someone is born
but what they grow to be okay i'll admit
this was actually said to cornelius
fudge in front of harry potter
rather than directly to harry but i
thought it would be okay to fudge
just the one see what i did there anyway
these wise words are pretty aggressively
said to fudge
the minister for magic in the hospital
wing and hogwarts after cedric diggory's
death
and voldemort's return to power during
the triwizard tournament
in the quote damodar is lecturing fudge
for placing too much importance on
bloodlines
and a wizard's purity of blood choosing
to ignore harry's warnings that
voldemort has returned
and instead believing the word of pure
blood families such as the malfoy's
even though they've been linked to
voldemort in the past as death eaters
it could be argued that this is because
harry's mother lily potter was
muggleborn
or fudge may simply not want to believe
that voldemort has returned
in any case the quote inspires the
listener namely harry
to once again put more stock in
someone's actions or choices
rather than their background or where
they came from the next inspirational
quote
comes from the beginning of harry potter
and the half blood prince
and it's a good one near the very
beginning of the book dumbledore says to
harry
let us step into the night and pursue
that flighty temptress
adventure look at dumbledore getting all
spicy
dumbledore says this to harry as they
prepare to leave the dursley's home on
number four privet drive for the last
time
although neither dumbledore nor harry
know this is the last time
as they leave in this scene dumbledore
explains to harry's aunt petunia
and uncle vernon that the magic i evoked
15 years ago
meant that harry has powerful protection
while he can still call this house home
so even though harry is technically
still protected by dumbledore's magic
until he becomes an adult at the age of
leaving the dursleys represents a leap
of faith for harry into the unknown
and possibly a very dangerous feature
which of course by the end of the
half-blood prince
we know is the case it's quite possible
that contrary to what he says
dumbledore asks the dursleys to allow
harry to return to pivot drive
at least one more time before his 17th
birthday dumbledore may have also known
that this particular departure did in
fact represent harry
embracing a dangerous future indeed
might as well make the loop of faith
sound as inspiring and exciting as
possible then right
which brings us to our fifth and final
inspirational quote
the dumbledore said to harry which takes
place in harry potter and the deathly
hallows
the quote is do not pity the dead harry
pity the living and above all those who
live
without love so of course leave it to
dumbledore to continue to inspire harry
even after his death
as he of course meets his demise in the
half blood prince
this heavy yet inspiring piece of advice
comes from dumbledore after harry has
been struck by voldemort savada kadavra
leaving him not quite dead in a strange
in between reality
a sort of limbo in the scene harry finds
himself in king's cross
of all places with his dead mentor
dumbledore
and an agonized creature who we are led
to believe is the piece of voldemort
that lived in harry as a horcrux
which jk rowling has described as a
receptacle
prepared by dark magic in which a dark
wizard has intentionally hidden a
fragment of his soul
for the purpose of attaining immortality
so
what exactly does dead dumbledore mean
by saying this to half-dead harry
well it would seem that he's trying to
inspire him to return to the living
rather than accept death the option to
die at this point would almost be
the easy way out as dumbledore says it's
really living that is difficult
those who are alive are the ones harry
should pity but
ultimately it seems that what dumbledore
is trying to share with harry
is that if he does choose to live he
should do so with love
this quote seems to encourage harry to
choose the difficult route of living
but only if he's willing to do so with
compassion which of course
he does and that's it for this video if
you enjoyed it
check out dumbledore's five most
powerful spells and
what dumbledore really saw in the mirror
of erised right here on harry potter
theory
please remember to like the video and
subscribe to the channel if you enjoyed
the content
as always leave your video suggestions
and comments down below
until next time all was well
you